so we
talked about this incredible distributed
system
created by wall street bets and then
there's a platform
which is robinhood which allows
investors to efficiently as far you can
correct me if i'm wrong but you know
there's those and there's others and
there's new mirai that
allow you to make it accessible for
people to
invest but uh that said
robin hood was uh in a centralized way
applied its power to restrict trading on
the stock that we're referring to
do you have a thought on actually like
all the things that happened
i don't know how much you were paying
attention uh to
sort of the shadiness uh around the
whole thing
do you think it was forced to do it or
was there something shady going on
what are your thoughts in general well i
think i
i want to see the alternate history like
i want to see the counter factual
history
of them not doing that not doing it how
bad would it have gotten
for hedge funds how much more damage
could have been done
if the momentum of these short squeezes
could continue
what happens when there are short
squeezes
uh even if um they're in a few stocks
they affect kind of all the other shorts
too and suddenly
um brokers are saying things like you
need to put up more collateral
so we had a short it wasn't gamestop
luckily it's blackberry and it went up
like 100 in a day
it was one of these meme stocks super
bad company the ais don't like it
okay they always think it's going down
what's a meme stock
a meme stock is kind of a new term for
these stocks that
catch memetic momentum on reddit
yeah um and so the meme stocks were
gamestop the biggest one game stunk as
elon calls it
amc um
and blackberry was one nokia was one
so these are high short interest stocks
as well so these are targeted stocks
some people say oh isn't it isn't it
adorable that these um
these people are investing money in
these companies that are
you know nostalgic it's like you're
going to the amc movie theater it's like
nostalgic it's like no
that's not why they're doing it it's
that they had a lot of short interest
that was the main thing and so they were
high chance of short squeeze
in saying i would love to see an
alternate history do you have a sense
that that
what is your prediction of what that
history would have looked like well
you wouldn't have needed very many more
days of that kind of chaos
to to hurt hedge funds
um i think it's underrated how how
damaging it could have been
uh because when your shorts
go up your collateral requirements for
them go up it's similar to robin hood
like we have a prime broker that says
said to us
uh you need to put up you know like 40
dollars per per 100
of short exposure and then the next day
they said actually you have to put up
you know all of it 100 and we were like
what
um but if that happens that if that
happens to all
the short all the commonly held hedge
fund shorts
because they're all kind of holding the
same things if that happens
not only do you have to cover the short
which means you're buying the bad
companies you need to sell your good
companies
in order to cover the short right so
suddenly like
all the good companies all the ones that
the hedge funds like are coming down
and all the all the ones that the hedge
funds hate are going up
in a cascading way
so i believe that if you could have had
a few more days of
game stock doubling amc doubling you
would have had more and more hedge fund
deleveraging but so hedge funds i mean
they get a lot of [ __ ] but
they do you have a sense that they do
some good for the world
i mean ultimately so okay first of all
wall street bets itself is
a kind of distributed hedge fund numeri
is a kind of hedge fund
so like a hedge fund is a very broad
category i mean
like if some of those were destroyed
would that be good for the world
or is it would there be coupled
with the the destroying the evil
shorting would there be just a lot of
pain in terms of investment
in good companies yeah a thing i like to
tell people
if they hate hedge funds is i don't
think you want to re-run
american economic history without hedge
funds
so so on math they're they're they're
good yeah
yeah they're good yeah you really
wouldn't want to uh because hedge funds
are kind of like picking up
um they're making liquidity right in
stocks and so
if you'd like if you love venture
capitalists
they're investing in new technology it's
so good you have to also kind of like
hedge funds
because they're the reason venture
capitalists exist
because their companies can have a
liquidity event when they go to the
public markets
so it's kind of essential that we have
them there are many different kinds of
them
i believe we could maybe get away with
only having an
ai hedge fund
but we don't necessarily need these evil
billions type hedge funds that make the
media and try to kill companies but we
definitely need hedge funds
you